we got a big victory for racial and
sexual justice yesterday
when united airlines tweeted out quote
our flight deck
should reflect the diverse group of
people on board our planes
every day that's why we plan for 50
of the 5 000 pilots we train in the next
decade to be women
or people of color this is very
important because what they're saying is
they're going to be implementing
a new reinvigorated affirmative action
program
for airplane pilots people whose job it
is to
shuttle hundreds of people at a time at
hundreds of miles per hour
through the sky in a tin can and if
they're focusing
on race and sex they're obviously not
focusing on
the best pilots that's not purely a
meritocracy but that's okay because it's
it's a matter of racial justice and i i
just can foresee it that when that plane
you know god forbid someday is going
down
and everyone's screaming i'm going to be
the nathan hale of affirmative action
i'm going to say my only regret
is that i have but one life to give for
diversity
equity and inclusion i understand
certain arguments for affirmative action
in certain
areas of society areas where
it you know it doesn't really matter
that much because like there there is
such a thing as historical grievance
there is
we're conservatives we recognize that
the past has some effect
on on the future and on the present so
you know i can understand it
when you get into the particulars of the
left's arguments for affirmative action
i think it falls apart but sure
some parts of society at the ice cream
shop
if there's an affirmative action oh okay
that doesn't really affect how i eat my
mint chocolate chip right
it's not a big deal at uh oh i don't
know
at the uh bus station
you know it's still you're still in a
moving vehicle but you know you're
moving kind of slowly you should you
should be all right
on the airplanes i i really i
i think you should focus on merit i
think
you should just have a rigorous test
yeah i don't know how to fly an airplane
i
wouldn't pass that test just a rigorous
test
to make sure that i don't drop out of
the sky
in the name of some fashionable leftist
idea but all the corporations are going
woke
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you